I have worked so hard in getting people
to the point where they can forget about
themselves and become nobody no one no
thing no wear and no time people when
they finally get this when they finally
realize that when they're that they're
pure Consciousness and they're connected
to the field and then they start putting
their attention on that frequency of
Oneness and wholeness and tune into it
and pay attention to it and stay present
with it and become more aware of it and
experience it and feel it moment after
moment after moment how much of people's
waking day do they put their attention
on the field and how much do they put
their attention on matter I'd say a
hundred percent of the time they put
their attention on matter now my
students are connecting to a greater
frequency they know how to get Beyond
themselves they can sit for extended
periods of time they could lock in if
they're connecting to that level of
frequency call the quantum field where
they're experiencing something cool that
you can't experience with your senses as
you evolve and unfold deeper into it you
experience less separation and more
Oneness and wholeness and the more
connected you are to it the less
distance between you as a Consciousness
and the consciousness of the objective
unified field hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because I need
them because I don't always wake up and
feel motivated to go take on the day and
the thing that saves me that helps me
every day is being around people who are
thinking bigger who are changing the
world and it gives me a little more
inspiration to go after my mission and
so I hope this video helps you go up to
yours today too so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Joe dispenza Joy
you're right outside the fundamental
rules of Newtonian physics and 3D
reality you're you're changing the field
and it changes matter instantaneously
so now we're seeing it happen in a
shorter amount of time because we're
getting better at it we're connecting to
that field more
and I know this to be the case because
when I witness it in week-long events
I I know the moment I can tell you when
the energy shifts in the room and now I
know it's going to be fun now I know get
ready because the Miracles are happening
it'll happen in one week
you tell me how a tumor can disappear on
a person's thyroid not one not two you
tell me how a man with a stroke who's
been paralyzed in his arm and leg that's
in his 70s paralyzed for years and now
lifting his arm above his head
how do you explain that is he he didn't
do that matter to matter he didn't
change his diet
he didn't do physical therapy
he didn't try to have a good attitude
and think positively there was none of
that
something in the field changed
and the pattern of that condition in the
field changed
so it is happening in a shorter amount
of time there is no rule
it's about the person's ability to pay
attention into Focus to be greater than
their body their environment and time
it's their sincerity it's the engagement
when they go sit down and do it they're
not doing oh man I gotta do this that's
the wrong attitude nothing's gonna
happen then you get there like I'm going
to connect with the Divine this is going
to be a great day I'm going to keep my
energy up I'm not getting up until I
feel like I'm empowered
that person's gonna have a rocking day
they're gonna have a good day I think
we've all experienced those
synchronicities where
you're thinking about something or you
have an intention and all of a sudden
you start to see reality kind of conform
itself around you in some way and you're
not going anywhere to get it somehow it
seems to be coming to you
and
there's a very direct correlation
between
energy and reality so when you start to
synchronize your energy to a possibility
that exists in the quantum field and you
have a coherent brain there's a very
very specific signal that we can send
out that's very very coherent and clear
and when we match that brain coherence
with heart coherence it is the heart
that acts as a magnet
and draws the experience back to us so
the thought being left with charge and
the feeling being the magnetic charge
and how you think and how you feel
broadcast information into the quantum
field and I think whatever we broadcast
into the field
is our experiment with Destiny
so we either create from the field or we
create from matter and if we create from
matter as bodies local in space and time
in three-dimensional reality we have to
move through space
to get what we want we have to move back
and forth to work and drive there to
manifest our dreams and in creating in
three-dimensional reality takes time and
it takes energy sometimes people get so
lost
in reality they forget what their dreams
were because there's too much time
between cause but thought and affect the
experience and that's what separation
does in three-dimensional reality
creating from the field and getting
Beyond yourself your associations to
everything physical and known and being
able to enter through
a small door
the eye of the needle the quantum field
passing through that eye of the needle
as pure Consciousness and connecting to
a field
and teaching people
how to create from the field instead of
from matter connected to that unified
field to Source energy when they create
from source and they're connected
to source and source is the cause that
creates matter the effect if we create
from Source connected to it from the
field instead of from matter we don't
have to go anywhere now to get what we
want we begin to draw the experiences to
us so by combining
heart coherence with brain coherence now
we have a Wi-Fi signal
and all we have to do is synchronize our
energy to some intention
with some emotion and tune in
to the energy of the future and the
longer you're conscious of this energy
the more you draw your future to you and
if you keep practicing it every day
it's going to become familiar to you and
all of a sudden that will be your
natural energy and when you change your
energy
you change your life and the more
coherent
the signatures electromagnetically
the more refined the experience we have
I think the greatest relationship that
you could ever have is with yourself
and taking time to be in the presence of
yourself and ask yourself important
questions like are you happy who am I
and instead of getting up and getting on
your cell phone and getting distracted
sit with your triple filtered water or a
glass of wine or whatever you're into JJ
sit down and answer the question without
being distracted the contemplation
process is the building process
neurologically
and for me I was I was just a guy I'm a
guy who loves God I'm a guy who loves a
Divine I'm a guy who loves mystery I'm
the guy who just never stops dovetailing
information and that's just me
and I never really planned on doing any
of this
I mean my theory is on life is make it
up as you go along and take the value
and run and and what the bleep became a
sensation and and all of a sudden I went
from a normal guy to being a rock star
and I was traveling around the world and
doing conferences all over the place and
I reached this point where I realized
that I wasn't living the work
and that really bothered me I was
disturbed by that I was really
uncomfortable and when you get
uncomfortable and nothing's making that
discomfort go away it's time to evolve
it's time to make a different choice and
I I clearly heard in my head during one
meditation stop making the same choices
and pause
I didn't know what that meant
except that I knew that I was relying on
all of this external stimulation to
build an identity that I really wasn't
and then I had to show up for people and
look a certain way and act a certain way
and that wasn't me
and it got disturbing for me
and I had this gap between the way I
appeared and the way I really was
and I didn't make time for myself and
make time to be the example I mean my
motive is always be the example of
everything that I teach if I'm not I'm
not I shouldn't be up here
uh I shouldn't be leading in my clinic
if I if I don't live those principles
myself if I don't live my life that way
and and so
um you know and at the height of uh my
popularity I disappeared I canceled all
my that's my friend's thought I was on
crack or something I thought I lost my
mind because you know what they were
saying you could make so much money and
I said I don't really I know how to make
money I really don't care about money I
really don't care about how happy I'm
gonna be with myself
and I broke from the world for six
months and retreated
and I really decided that if I presented
myself back to the world that I wasn't
going to be seduced by it in the same
way
that I really wanted to be the example
of everything that I taught and I wanted
to lead events in a way that empowered
people I never wanted it to be about me
I wanted to be about you I think that
the greatest belief that you could have
is the belief in yourself and when you
believe in yourself you believe in
possibilities and when you believe in
possibilities you have to believe in
yourself
so people that enter this work
uh come with a certain amount of chronic
disbelief that they could actually
change their life or change their health
condition
when you see the scientific research
that in seven days a novice meditator
their biology literally looks like
they're in a different life and they're
in a ballroom and there's nothing very
special about a ballroom I've been to
thousands of ballrooms and the
environment isn't that stimulating that
those changes are coming from within you
see the data and you look at how cancer
cells
actually the energy in cancer cells when
you take the plasma of meditators
advanced meditators and you subject that
plasma to all kinds of cancer cells
seventy percent of the mitochondrial
function actually diminishes in the
cancer cell cancer cells love to
multiply and they love to move you take
energy out of the cancer cell you're
taking life out of the cancer cell and
people see that data it gives them hope
it gives them the idea that it's
possible now
when someone stands on the stage with
stage four cancer that has spread to
their bones to the uterus to their lungs
to the liver to all the tissues of their
body and you ask any physician who's
seen stage four cancer in Bones it's
very unlikely you're going to see a
reversal and you see the person stand on
the stage and tell their story and it's
not glamorous it's a real life story
and there's no evidence of cancer in any
of her tissues any longer no cancer in
her bones the pet scans show that
there's a complete reversal
that's the four minute mile that's the
person speaking the truth and invariably
somebody in the audience is examining
that person's story
and they're thinking if that person can
do it I can do it as well also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there if you keep thinking the same
thoughts if you keep making the same
choices and keep doing the same things
you keep creating the same experiences
you keep feeling the same emotions I
don't know let's be conservative
you do that for 10 years
you would have to agree with me then
that it would become more automatic
would be become more unconscious
so your personality creates your
personal reality that's it that is it
and your personality is made of how you
think how you act and how you feel
so keep thinking the same way keep
acting the same way keep feeling the
same way
your personality is the same in your
personality personal reality would be
the same as well so if you wanted to
change your life
if you wanted to change your personal
reality you would have to change your
personality
and then you'd have to start thinking
about what you've been thinking about
and decide if you really want to believe
that any longer
and when does the story end
it's it's that moment that you become so
conscious of that thought you're so
tired of it
you're so aware of it that you would
never let it slip by your awareness ever
again
you catch yourself complaining and
blaming and making excuses and feeling
sorry for yourself and that's been your
unconscious program
then the moment you become conscious of
those unconscious behaviors
you're out of the program you're only in
the program when you're unconscious and
so it takes an enormous amount of energy
and awareness to separate from those
programs and then there's those emotions
that we feel every single day that are
so familiar to us that we don't even
know what they are
we just feel guilty we don't even know
what's guilt it's just how we feel
and the stronger the emotions that we
have to
experiences in our life the more altered
we are inside of us when the chemistry
changes inside of us the brain Narrows
the focus on the cause and takes a
snapshot
or a series of snapshots and that's
called a long-term memory
and so then makes total sense then that
a person by every time they relive that
event in their life they're making the
same chemistry and their brain and their
body and their bodies literally
believing it's living that experience
over and over again
and now the body's so in the past
that it's the mind of the past
so then
the act of becoming so conscious that
you don't go unconscious
is a changing of consciousness
how many times do we have to forget
until we stop forgetting and start
remembering that is the moment of change
if you're living in stress and you're
living in survival and that system is
switched on then everything will be a
threat everything will be a danger
everything will be a reason to rush to
be impatient to be frustrated to be
judgmental because that's that's the
Consciousness that's the emotion we're
living by so now you you have a problem
with a co-worker you have a problem with
your partner whatever it is that you use
as an example and you have to give a
presentation no no you really have one
of two choices either be victimized
by those conditions in your life and you
stay in that emotional state and I'll
say to you Jay worry that way while I'm
this way because of this person the
circumstance the person or circumstance
is controlling the way I feel and the
way I think anything that controls the
way I feel and the way I think I'm
victim to right okay or I actually can
be a Creator now okay so when it's the
hardest it matters the most okay so
there's gonna be a story a valid story
that's going to go along with those
emotions that you're gonna have to give
up that you can address at another time
from a different state
if you're altered in that state and you
say something you do something you write
the email you send the text you'll
always regret it you'll always say I
should have never said that I should
have never done that we've got to learn
that we're in an altered state at that
time so there's only one of two choices
you either stay there the whole day and
tell everybody that story
or you say okay let me take a moment
remember that this is the experiment
called life okay let me practice getting
relaxed in my Army slow the animal down
let me practice I'll take a few minutes
now let me breathe let me get my state
back let me change everything okay let
me remember who I am who I want to be
when I open my eyes and let me practice
that again now even if you had to do
that 10 times in one day I would say it
was a day worth living I would say it
was a day worth living and when we do
walking meditations
uh in our our Retreats we're doing
walking meditations so you can practice
doing it with your eyes open yeah like
if you're going to be relaxed in your
heart and awake in your brain and you
can do it with your eyes closed okay
let's take it out for a test drive yeah
let me open my eyes let me pay a little
bit more attention to my inner World let
me practice feeling this feeling when we
practice feeling this way and let my
brain do what it does let me get to
finally change my physiology let me
change my state let me walk as the
healed personally walk as the Abundant
person let me walk as if my prayers are
answering me walk in the state if I keep
practicing that over and over it's going
to become a habit right yes so so we hit
it as many ways as we can we have at
least
seven or eight different breaths that we
do because we see how they all work in
the brain
we have all kinds of meditations we have
Sitting meditations we have standing and
walking meditation laying down
meditations because we want you to be
able to do it because your eyes open
with your eyes go standing walking any
way you can so that you don't default
and return back to that person now if
you do default you didn't fail that's a
program you just went unconscious and
how many times
do we have to forget
until we stop forgetting and start
remembering that's the moment of change
no one no one cares how many times you
fell off the bicycle if you ride the
bicycle now you ride the bike so is it's
the constant process uh every single day
and I think that sometimes we look for
evidence in our life and it hasn't
happened and I think it's so important
that we still show up yeah yeah because
that's the that's where you're changing
the most and when you get to that point
where you could care less
if it happens or not because you feel so
happy so grateful for who you are get
ready because your life is going to
begin to change in magical ways we've
been primed over time from thousands of
years that the unknown is a scary place
and so then by thinking the same
thoughts
by making the same choices by doing the
same things that create the same
experiences that produce the same
feelings and emotions in time
and those emotions begin to influence
your very same thoughts
causes our biology to stay exactly the
same
and so we afford people new information
new knowledge new understandings New
Philosophy new Theory
and we Inspire them to make new choices
to begin to do new things and break the
old habit and relearn
to create new experiences and produce
new emotions
and in just a matter of four days people
begin to up regulate genes that begin to
heal their body and change the way their
body functions just by changing the way
they think changing the way they act and
changing the way they feel
the problem is is that the brain and
body locked into the past
clinging to the known and familiar where
the body has been conditioned to be the
mind
the moment a person decides to do
something differently or make a
different choice
they feel uncomfortable
because they've left the known and
they've left the familiar and if the
body has been conditioned to be the mind
the animal the servant is now the master
and it wants to return back to familiar
territory
and as we step out into the unknown and
we feel that discomfort the uncertainty
not being able to predict the next
moment
the body begins to influence the mind
and we start to hear the same thoughts
and if we respond to that thought that's
hardwired in the brain and we accept it
we believe it we surrender to it without
saying is this the truth
that same thought leads to the same
Choice which leads to the same behavior
which creates the same experience and
produces the same feeling and the same
emotion and the person says this feels
right to me
but all it is is that it feels familiar
and so the process of change then
is to become conscious
of your unconscious thoughts
and the more conscious you become of
your unconscious thoughts the less you
will go unconscious to them in your
waking day what is healing for you
I think people come to our work Florence
for all kinds of reasons they they come
to heal
they come to find love
they come to or to get beyond their
traumas of the past they come for a
mystical experience they come for wealth
or abundance
um but really I think when people really
come for as wholeness and and and when
you see brain and hard coherence uh this
this this Union of the two of the of the
heart and the mind or the heart and the
Brain
um there is a sense of wholeness there
is a sense of healing and
I think if you heal your heart
you heal your mind
I think you heal your mind do you you
heal your heart uh and when people
finally Break Free
from those chains of the emotions that
they lived by on a daily basis when they
break free of their habituations even in
the way they speak when they overcome
their hard-wired beliefs that they've
thought over and over again until they
accepted him without without any
analysis
when they overcome that programming uh
to a certain degree
uh they that wholeness that they feel
is uh the healing
in and of itself they're not waiting for
their healing or their health to change
so they could feel gratitude so they
could feel whole they actually
understand that when they feel gratitude
and they still feel wholeness that's
when their Healing Begins so then
anything that causes us to move out of
that state
within us
a reaction or response from someone or
something in our life that would move us
from that state of grace
I promise you if you're truly in the
river of change and you wanted to heal
you would think about how you would
respond differently
to that person or circumstance the next
time so you wouldn't lose that feeling
because you would actually no longer be
signaling the same genes in the same way
the moment you felt familiar emotions
you would be signaling old genes and so
the person who understands the what
in what they're doing and the why that
if I live by this emotional state every
single day if the environment signals
the gene okay
and the end product of an experience in
the environment is an emotion if I live
by this emotion I could signal genes of
head of my environment and I could
actually change my health
now this is when meditation no longer
becomes a have to
this isn't that when meditation becomes
very practical because the person is
going to rehearse in their mind
how they are going to think in their day
what they are going to believe and
they're going to repeat it enough times
and a belief is just a thought you keep
thinking over and over again until it
becomes hardwired in your brain they're
going to review that belief and they're
going to keep firing and wiring it
they're going to change the way they
respond to their co-worker to their
spouse uh to their to their boss to the
news they're going to change their
response and they're going to rehearse
it in their mind the mental rehearsal as
you know changes the brain to look like
it's already happened they're going to
say I gotta feel this feeling
if it takes me a hundred times today
to feel this feeling I'm going to bring
it up a hundred times over and over
again so I get so good at feeling it I
can bring it up whenever I want
and stop from default right
and then when people do that that the
overcoming process is the becoming
process that so many people have healed
in this work
and they didn't even realize that when
they were sitting and their body was
raging and out of balance and they were
working with settling it down and
overcoming those survival emotions
overcoming those programs those
habituations that that overcoming
process was actually the becoming
process so many people when they
actually got to the point where they
were so happy with themselves
so in love with themselves so in love
with life so grateful for being like
they could care less
if they had their health condition they
no longer identified with it any longer
that was the moment it went away and you
ask that person where where is the the
the the disease they'll tell you it's in
the old person they healed themselves by
changing themselves they they're happy
with themselves now they don't want to
be anybody else being victimized by a
circumstance in your life literally
means that that event that circumstance
that person that condition is actually
causing you to feel emotionally and
think in terms of memories equal to that
circumstance and that circumstances
actually changes your state of being so
you're thinking the same way and you're
feeling the same way in response to the
environment is the same we can guarantee
that your life is going to stay the same
because you're the same and yes that
person why are you unhappy why are you
frustrated why are you sad they'll say
the this condition that this person is
actually making me feel and think this
way well anything that makes us feel and
think a certain way that we don't think
we have any control over for the most
part we're victims so we're as a species
become victimized by the conditions in
our life and it's the environment then
that is controlling the way we feel and
the way we think so the idea is if you
can change the way you think and change
the way you feel
could you begin to produce outcomes or
effects in your life that cause you to
believe that you're the creator of your
life instead of the victim of your life
which means then you would have to think
greater than that circumstance and you
would have to feel differently in the
presence of that circumstance and if you
truly could
and begin to create an outcome the
synchronicity the Serendipity the
coincidence that happens in your life
you're going to pay attention to what
you did and you're going to realize that
on some level you had a hand in that you
know that you were a participant in that
our interest is to teach people how to
to reverse that process
every person every circumstance every
condition every place every object that
you own is mapped neurologically in your
brain so your brain is a record of the
past it's it's an artifact the
repository of everything you've learned
intellectually your experience and
products of experience are called
emotions the memories that we have in
our life produces familiar emotions or
our response to anybody that we know in
our life there's a neurological Network
for your boss for your co-worker for
your ex and for most people they're
they're their their interaction in the
environment is causing their environment
to control their thinking or their
personal reality is controlling their
personality so our interests to see us
of oh if your personality is made of how
you think how you act and how you feel
is it possible if I begin to change the
way I think change the way I act and
change the way I I feel should my life
change because I'm changing and so the
interest for us then is to be able to
meet the challenges and conditions in
our life from a greater level of
Consciousness and and not be victimized
by those circumstances but to take time
and and to review how you're going to
think how you're going to act and how
you're going to feel that's meditation
and review how you're not going to think
you know how you're not going to act and
how you're not going to feel it just
turns out that tends to be 95 percent of
who we are as those unconscious programs
so it's so much easier to forget and
then to remember because it's the
majority of who we are you know after a
certain point in our life so changing
that process the overcoming process of
that same self somehow begins to produce
a facts in people's lives and that's
that's kind of the exciting part about
being a creator of your life I always
tell my children that your personality
creates your personal reality and if you
want to change something in your life
then on a fundamental level you have to
look at the thoughts you're thinking to
see if they're serving you notice the
behaviors and that you're demonstrating
and see if those are loving to yourself
and begin to look at the emotions that
you've memorized that become part of
your identity and children begin to
understand this very naturally because
the law with children
that I've believed from the time my
children were very young is that if you
give them the facts they will interpret
the laws so because of mirror neurons
your children are paying attention to
more of what you do than what you say
so you can't say to your kids clean your
room and have a messy room you
understand because they're going to want
they're going to look at your room
subconsciously automatically
and I was uh interviewing doing an
interview for this book someone was
interviewing interviewing me for this
book and they said can you tell me about
the terrible twos I said it's really
simple
what do you do the first uh
year of your child's life
oh look how cute he is look how cute she
is look oh and then all of a sudden at
one years old what happens
they stand up right and they stand up
and their brain is so neuroplastic and
they go wow look at this vase I wonder
how it's made oh it holds water and then
it begins the child begins to interact
with the environment out of curiosity
pulling things breaking things and then
what do you do
no
you do that for a whole year and then
you say at two years old put your shoes
on and what's the child say no
no that's mirror neurons it's only
mirroring Behavior
so we know then that
children pay attention because of those
mirror neurons more based on what they
observe than what they're told and
wouldn't you agree then if you were
changing a habit whether you wanted to
lose weight or stop smoking or stop
eating chalk or whatever people do
you're gonna have to look at the things
that cause you to return back to the
same choice
and you're going to review in your mind
oh my gosh I know that little devil is
going to come up and say go ahead you
know start tomorrow chocolate's good for
you it's all right you know everybody
else is eating it you know
and you have to become selective about
that thought's going to come up and you
have to overcome that thought would you
agree because that thought's going to
lead to the same choice right
so you have to review in your mind who
you no longer want to be
and then you're gonna have to observe
your behaviors
and as you begin to observe your
behaviors you're going to have to make a
decision with such firm intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy that's greater
than the hardwired programs in your
brain and the emotional addiction or
memory in your body and your body
responds to a new mind it gets a rush of
energy and when it gets that Rush of
energy you're giving it a sampling of
the future you're grabbing the reins of
the stallion and you're pulling those
reins in and you're saying I'm the boss
and the body the animal begins to
respond to your mind
and then you have to look at the
emotions
the feelings that you look forward to
whether it's guilt or shame or
unworthiness that's become so familiar
you don't even know that you're feeling
that way it just feels like you
and you have to decide then does this
emotion belong in my future
do I want to bring this into my future
because as long as I'm living by this
emotion I'm living in my past
so then as you begin to observe those
states of Mind and Body you begin to
objectify your subjective self and just
like viewing a videotape of yourself
playing baseball playing tennis dancing
a dance speaking publicly whatever it is
if you can observe yourself it means you
can self-correct better wouldn't you
agree
so then the process of change then is
becoming conscious of your unconscious
self and when you begin to decide every
day who you no longer want to be you are
you are retiring the old self
and the body will crave the emotional
payoff just like an addiction
and you have to understand that that's
the biological neurological chemical
hormonal physiological genetic death of
the old self and when you begin to
understand that you can work then in
creating a new self
and you can begin to emotionally give
your body a taste of the future
ahead of the actual event and as we said
last night the emotional signature is
exactly what signals the gene
because the body does not know the
difference between the actual experience
in your life that creates the emotion
and the emotion that you're fabricating
by thought alone so the body it's the
same I started studying this concept
called neuroplasticity where it says
that we're not hardwired to be a certain
way for the rest of our lives that the
brain is adaptable and it's changeable
and we can rewire our brain I started
studying some of that research and then
I started studying epigenetics that
we're not doomed by our genes that we
are really marvels of adaptability and
change and and we could literally uh
signal new genes and change our
expression of of Gene potential and I
started thinking uh about how the mind
influenced the body and I had to study
uh psychoneuroimmunology
neurochemistry and neural hormones and
and then of course led me to quantum
physics and how subjective mind has an
effect on the objective world and
started this journey of understanding my
own personal transformation
and I think after you have an initiation
like this and this was my initiation it
was my wake-up call in fact I wouldn't
be sitting here today if it didn't
happen to me
you know I think when you have moments
like this in your life and you have
some Transcendence of your your
conditions
and you have a breakthrough I don't
think you can go back to business as
usual I don't think you could go back to
being the same person again and I was in
a lot of ways that change a young man
and so I started my journey in in
looking to find answers and and did my
best to combine both the spiritual
understanding of what happens to me with
the science
and so after a period of time I started
studying spontaneous remissions I I
wanted to understand if if there were
other people
um that had same or similar conditions
that were treating conventionally or
unconventionally
and they were staying the same or
getting worse and all of a sudden they
got better
and I wanted to know if there was a
cause that somehow produced the effect
and so I interviewed hundreds and
hundreds of people that had some type of
spontaneous remission and over time I
began to realize that those changes
weren't so spontaneous after all that
there was some effect number one they
all believed that there was an
intelligence within them that was giving
them life that was that same
intelligence that I just talked about
and its function is for balance
restoration repair and regeneration it
is to maintain the body in its balance
and all of those biological functions
that you and I take for granted are
under the control of the autonomic
nervous system and the autonomic nervous
system is the automatic nervous system
and so
they all believe that there was some
intelligence that was giving them life
and they all believed that somehow
whatever you want to call that
intelligence they had to take time to
begin to make contact with him and to
begin to give it a specific design just
like I did
and again once again surrender uh their
creation to this to this automatic mind
that does the healing for us
the second thing they had in common is
on some level they began to take
responsibility for their own health they
started to say what was my state of mind
and body that may have contributed to
this disease whether it was cancer Ms
thyroid condition
what what was it that I had been doing
for the last 10 years or last 20 years
that could have had an effect on it what
were the thoughts that I was thinking
what were the actions or habits that I
went unconscious to how did I speak
and they looked at certain emotions that
they lived by that they may have
mismanaged and they started to become
conscious of those unconscious states of
mind and body
and this was an important element
because this was the process of breaking
the habit of being themselves in other
words they started realizing that it was
their unconscious thoughts and feelings
and and behaviors that had some effect
on their body and if they thought well
if I was thinking acting and feeling
this way if I start to change my
thoughts if I start to change how I
speak how I act if I could begin to give
up certain emotions that would keep me
connected to the past and start feeling
differently
would it begin to produce an effect in
my my body and and um
they began their own personal journey of
of changing from one state into another
I thought that was really important
because when I started studying this I I
realized that mine had the most dramatic
effect on the body and I went back to
school and started studying Neuroscience
in more detail and and I started to
discover that there is a very strong
correlation between how we think because
every thought we think produces a
chemical that chemical signals our body
to feel certain ways so then I said that
the hormones of stress cause us to
narrow our focus on the material world
because the arousal of those chemicals
causes us to pay attention to what's
causing it and we become very object
focused very materialistic because the
hormones of stress heighten our senses
and it causes us now to become more
aware of our body more aware of the
environment and more aware of time
and so when you've been doing your
meditation and I've asked you to take
your attention off your body and go from
somebody to a nobody
to take your attention off the people in
your life
that you identify with and to go from a
someone to a no one
to no longer think about the objects or
things in your life from your cell phone
your computer your car to all the
elements that you are associating with
that are known you're going to go from
something to nothing if you're not
thinking about where you're sitting
where you live where you work where you
need to be
you're going to go from somewhere to
nowhere and if you're not thinking about
the predictable future or the familiar
past you're going to go from some time
to no time the act of you practicing
that and taking your attention off of
everything known we could say that you
are disinvesting all of your attention
and energy
out of this three-dimensional reality
out of the known and putting it on the
unknown
and so you've been practicing becoming
pure Consciousness and it is the act of
opening your awareness when I ask you to
open your awareness into the Blackness
there's a reason for that because when
you go from a narrow Focus
to a broad Focus or an open focus and
you take your attention off the material
world and put it on nothing when you are
no longer focusing on the known and
broadening your focus and putting it on
the unknown you're putting your
attention on nothing in fact you are
tuning in to energy and frequency now
we learned that when people did this
properly when they broadened their focus
and they were sensing space
the act of sensing space caused them to
stop thinking and stop analyzing now
when they stop thinking and analyzing
they stop activating those circuits in
their brain that was causing their brain
to Fire incoherently and when they did
this properly when they were sensing
instead of thinking and analyzing they
began to change their brain now
let's talk about how they did this
I want to talk to you about a simple
understanding of brain waves when you're
living by the hormones of stress and I
said you're in that aroused State your
brain moves into a brainwave pattern
called high beta brain waves Now High
beta is that alarm state is that
emergency State that's the aroused state
but normal beta brainwave patterns is
like most of you right now you're
listening to me right now there's no
danger there's no threat and your
brain's job is to create meaning or
order between what's going on in the
outer world and what's going on in your
inner world and so your brain has a lot
to keep track of your senses plug you
into the three-dimensional reality think
about it
if you couldn't see if you couldn't hear
you couldn't smell you couldn't taste
you couldn't feel you would have no
experience of the three-dimensional
reality so your senses plug you into the
three-dimensional Reality by the same
means
when you're under the hormones of stress
and there's an arousal the senses are
heightened and when that occurs now now
you've got to pay more attention you're
more Vigilant so in that kind of state
where you're processing information
everything you're seeing right now
everything you're listening to and
hearing what you're feeling what you're
smelling your brain's got a lot to keep
track of and and as it processes all
this information and you're relaxed in
your environment and you're awake
your brain functions in what's called
beta brainwave patterns
if I said to you there's a test that you
have to take at the end of this course
your brain would perk up a little bit
more and you would move into what's
called mid-range beta
in high range beta it's three times as
high as low range beta and that's the
emergency State and in that high beta
State that's when you're shifting your
attention from one person to one problem
to one object to one place to one thing
to another meeting to another problem to
your past to your future and you
activate these circuits and the Brain
fires in coherently in a high beta State
and people get stuck in that state it's
like it's like driving your sports car
in first gear on the freeway so we've
done thousands and thousands of brain
scans
in addition we partner with heart math
Institute and we measure hard coherence
and hard coherence of course is a
function of a person's ability to
sustain elevated emotional states
that when we live in fear we live in
anxiety we live in resentment
frustration and patience the heart beats
very incoherently when we're living by
those survival States those stressful
States
and when we teach people to combine a
clear intention which is a function of a
coherent brain
with an elevated emotion which is a
function of a coherent heart
that when you start feeling gratitude
when you start feeling inspired and you
start feeling the love for Life The Joy
for existence
turns out the heart starts beating more
coherently
and the Heart producing a measurable
magnetic field that energy that
frequency carries information
so we teach our students to use that
energy to then create a future or to
change their health because that energy
will carry a thought or an intention or
a message
and when that occurs they begin to
change their own expression of
electromagnetic signature around their
body
and so when we change our energy we
change our health and we change our life
so we've done thousands and thousands of
HRV measurements and what we do in our
workshops is we give our students
a HRV device to wear on their chest with
a lead
and we're measuring their heart and how
it functions over a 24-hour period of
time and when they walk into a
meditation and they sit down
they start the process we want to see if
they're able to sustain that state for
an extended period of time and then when
we can see the changes that they make
then we know we can tell them what
you're doing is actually correct keep
doing it or if they're not doing it well
enough we can give them more information
on how to do it better
and so
our students then are combining that
clear intention with an elevated emotion
it's beginning to create changes in
their biology I wrote a book called
evolve your brain and then there was a
documentary called what the bleeps we
know and that became a very popular
documentary and open people's mind up to
what was possible as human beings
but when I was um
touring with the scientists and
researchers uh that were in this movie I
started paying attention to the
questions people asked when we were
doing these seminars around the world
and they kept asking
um okay
our thoughts have some effect on our
bodies our thoughts have some effect on
our minds our thoughts have some effect
on our lives okay uh how do you do it I
thought that was a great question the
second thing is if your personality
creates your personal reality and in
order to create a new personal reality
you have to change your personality well
how do we change and why is it so hard
it changed I thought that was a really
great question the third question was
what do you do I remember the moment I
watched a woman
with Ms that was confined to a
wheelchair for about 10 years after one
meditation stand up
out of that wheelchair and start to walk
around
actually she was dancing around
and I realized right in that moment that
something happened to that person in
other words what happened biologically
what happened scientifically what was
there a was there a change in gene
expression was there a change in mind
what did she do that began to affect her
body
then all of a sudden I just could not go
back to business as usual it was there
was too much uh too many questions that
I had asked and too much evidence now
because we started seeing it more and
more as we kept teaching these workshops
and
I thought okay uh now we're starting to
see these changes let's organize a team
of scientists and researchers and begin
to do some measurements and so I wrote
another book called breaking the habit
of being yourself and that was more of
the how to teach people the beginning
stages of how to change how to unlearn
and relearn how to break the habit of
the old self and reinvent the new self
how to prune synaptic connections and
Sprout new connections how to deprogram
and reprogram unfire and unwire re-fire
and rewire to lose your mind and create
a new one how do we unmemorize emotions
that keep us connected to the past and
then recondition the body to a new mind
into a new emotion that keeps us
believing in the new future
and so
we we organize this team of scientists
and we started doing uh brain scans we
started doing quantitative eegs we were
taking measurements of people that would
come to our events go through four days
of training or four and a half days of
training and then we would scan their
brain at the end and we wanted to see
the changes weren't just in their mind
that they were in fact in their brain
and then we started doing something
really important as we started measuring
people's brains in real time during a
meditation to see any fundamental clues
that could help us understand their
inner workings and we gained so much
knowledge about the process of change
and transformation we measured heart
rate variability we know that when a
person is resentful when they're
impatient when they're frustrated their
heart beats very differently compared to
when they're a state of gratitude or Joy
or inspiration or feeling care and
kindness
we measured the energy of the room we
wanted to see if a collective group of
people could begin to affect the
environment around them the energy in
the room we measure the energy fields
around their body we measure the energy
centers of their body because we did
certain things to influence those
individual energy centers that are under
the control of the autonomic nervous
system
we measured gene expression we now know
that you can change your gene expression
in four days we measured immune
regulation we wanted to see if people
gave up those emotions of stress and
went into more elevated emotions if it
would strengthen their immune system if
it gave him more energy for growth and
repair he measured telomere lengths we
wanted to see if people could sustain
the proper homeostasis and balance and
self-regulate and do meditations every
day for 60 days only five out of seven
days a week if it began to change their
telomeres the little shoestring caps on
the end of the DNA that determine your
biological age and we saw that three out
of four people that did their
meditations on a regular basis change
their genetic Destiny they changed the
future
and if you asked me over 10 12 years ago
if I thought that I would be seeing the
changes that I'm currently seeing
presently I probably would have told you
maybe once or twice but um
there's been a huge shift there has been
a significant change there's been a
movement and there's a momentum of
people that are beginning to understand
what they're doing and why they're doing
it broadening your awareness starts to
create brain coherence and when the
brain starts functioning in a more
orderly and coherent way and it begins
to synchronize in those different
compartments of the brain start working
together there comes a moment where the
two hemispheres of the brain start to
synchronize into balance and the union
of polarity the union of opposites the
union of Duality is called wholeness and
now we are creating from wholeness
instead of from lack or separation and
this is where it gets exciting because
when a person does this properly
and they can practice it our research
shows that people can change their brain
waves in one second in four seconds in
five seconds and 12 seconds and 13
seconds and 19 seconds why because they
understand the process of getting Beyond
themselves
so why is that important for you because
up until this point
whether you know it or not you have
began the process of practicing brain
coherence the first part of the formula
and so
when you open up your awareness in your
next meditation I'm going to ask you as
if you had no eyes no ears no body to
feel to smell to taste as if you were
just an awareness I'm going to ask you
to sense this Blackness and I'm going to
ask you to sense its depth I'm going to
say how far can your awareness go into
endless space
and all I want you to do is sense its
infinite depth I'm going to ask you to
become aware that there's infinite
Blackness on both sides of you and all I
want you to do is broaden your focus and
to sense it to feel it to stay connected
to it and the act of opening your
awareness and sensing space slows your
brain waves down I'm going to ask you to
become aware that there's Infinite Space
behind you and the act of sensing that
Infinite Space behind you causes your
brain to start to fire more orderly
we've measured this thousands of times
and as if you were just an awareness in
that Blackness I'm going to say to you
now it's time to become nobody no one
nothing nowhere and no time and take
your attention off of everything known
and to invest it into the unknown and
like investing into a bank account the
longer you linger in the unknown
the more you create possibilities in
your life and if you find your mind
returning to your body to your pain to
your drives to your emotions to your
habits
to thinking about certain people or
objects or places or things in your
known predictable reality to thinking
about the familiar past or the eventual
future simply become aware that your
attention is on the known
investing back into this
three-dimensional reality stop relax
return back to the present moment and
unfold back into possibility into the
Blackness you say that we have to master
the concept of the present moment what
does that mean
well there's so much talk about the
present moment and being present in the
power of now but
um most people
um
they spend the majority of their life uh
95 of the time either living by some
past emotion or some past habit or
anticipating the future based on the
past and so we're very rarely in the
present moment and and paying attention
is being present and it's a skill just
like anything else the more you practice
it the better you get at it so think
about it the feelings and emotions are
the end product of past experiences and
you can remember experience is better
because you can remember how they feel
if you wake up in the morning and you
have to search for The Familiar feeling
called you every morning and and that
feeling is unhappiness or frustration or
lack or insecurity or fear
the moment you get in touch with that
emotion you're starting your day from
the past because the emotion is a record
of the past now if that emotion is
connected to memories that are mapped
neurologically in your brain of certain
people at certain places at certain
times with certain things then the
moment you feel that emotion you
associate that emotion with the past
memory then you're activating circuits
in your brain from the past so if how
you think and how you feel creates your
state of being and thoughts of the
vocabulary of the brain and feelings are
the vocabulary of your body then your
entire state of being is in the past and
most people are living in the past so
their body
is their unconscious mind and it doesn't
know the difference between an
experience in their life that creates an
emotion and an emotion that they're
creating by thought alone so the body
it's exactly the same so those emotions
start driving people's thoughts
and if they can't think greater than how
they feel and feelings have become the
means of thinking and they believe that
their thoughts have something to do with
their Destiny then they're thinking in
the past
so they're creating more of the same
life and by the same means if they wake
up in the morning and they come back to
their senses and they start out with the
same routine that they did yesterday and
they're going through a series of
routine habits of going through the
toilet making coffee eating breakfast
taking a shower driving the work the
same way then we could say for the most
part a person's future is nothing more
than a replication of the past and
they're not in the present moment and if
they keep doing that over and over again
that becomes a habit
and a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
frequent repetition The Habit is when
you've done something so many times the
body has become the mind so for most
people their body is dragging them into
a predictable future and they're on
autopilot based on what they've done in
the past and they've lost their free
will to a program I think anybody who is
alive right now
who is engaged in life
has noticed the quickening
taking place in other words everybody
feels like more things are happening
in a shorter amount of time so there's
an acceleration and time is a construct
in our mind there's no circuitry there's
no Hardware in our brain
to be able to understand time it's a
construct based on our past and how we
predict the future
but
information
is so readily available
in our world right now that in an age of
information ignorance is a choice
so you don't need an authority to gain
information any long you don't need a
priest you don't need a governor don't
need a doctor you don't need a teacher
you can access information at your
fingertips
so then as you begin to discern the
information with discernment the proper
and right information
you begin to develop some type of
empowerment because all of a sudden
you're seeing possibilities
that you never saw before without that
information so you wake up you become
more aware
so the knowledge creates awareness
awareness creates Consciousness
Consciousness and energy are connected
so there's a change in energy globally
going on with the world now that that
that knowledge and that change of energy
has effects on paradigms that are no
longer a vibrational match with that new
level of Consciousness so you see a
political system that's unraveling you
see
economics economic systems unraveling
they're unspiring they're unraveling
they can't sustain themselves with this
new energy
you see journalism the environment
education religion
uh
uh medicine it's all unraveling because
something greater has to come as a
result of a change in Consciousness now
no victims here
because when you and I negotiated
from a soul level to be here at this
time this is the time we've been waiting
for this is this is where it's happening
in the Milky Way this is happening here
because there's a true coming of a new
Consciousness it's not one person that's
coming it's a group it's a collective
Consciousness that's emerging and
emergencies uh one mind one heart
and the way you control people
is you give them misinformation based on
emotions you control people by
controlling their emotions and media and
television and advertisement is a great
seduction that people can watch you the
news and get really angry then change
the channel and watch a football game
and get very excited and change the
channel and watch a sitcom and laugh and
change the channel and watch a drama and
you can change your emotional state
because of Technology
so then it means then most people are
relying consciously or subconsciously on
things outside of them to make them feel
a certain way and so
my interest is to provide the proper
content of information
scientifically to people so that they
reason that this is actually possible
then to give them the opportunity to
experience that philosophy and get their
behaviors to match their intentions as
many ways as I can now if I do that
properly people are going to have new
experiences experiences are going to
change the circuitry in their brain
learning makes connections but
experience enriches connections the end
product of an experience is an emotion
so when you start feeling worthy when
you start feeling a love for yourself
when you start feeling A Love For Life
when you start feeling
truly grateful the moment you feel that
emotion you're teaching your body
to understand what your mind is
understood and living in stress is when
your response to the environment
causes you to activate the autonomic
nervous system
and when you activate that autonomic
nervous system a branch of it called the
sympathetic nervous system the
fight-or-flight nervous system is
mobilizing all of the body's energy
all of the body's resources for some
danger in the outer environment are you
with me still and it mobilizes all this
energy to prepare the body to do one of
three things to fight
to run or to freeze and hide
and so the mobilization and tapping all
of the body's resources causes the heart
to race
respiratory rate to increase pupils that
dilate digestive juices the shutdown
blood sent to the extremities the immune
system dials up then dials down
we mobilize all this glucose
to have the energy to be able to run
fight or hide now in the short term
that works really well all organisms in
nature can tolerate short-term stress
the human beings were a little bit more
complex
sometimes it's not the Predator that
we're afraid of it's the person sitting
next to us at work sometimes it's the
news sometimes it's a reaction to
someone or something
and the constant knocking the brain and
body out of balance causes that
imbalance to become a new balance and
now the person is headed for some type
of breakdown some type of disease
because no organism can live in that
state an emergency state for an extended
period of time this is The Telltale
moment if human beings have what it
takes
to truly be able to
solve the problems
that we've created from a limited level
of Consciousness from a greater level of
Consciousness the answers are all around
us we just got to wake up whatever it is
from global warming to
politics monetary systems
it's all there it's just we just have to
emerge
as a collective
that's connected
by the energy of Love of gratitude of
freedom
and to not shrink in fear or hostility
or suffering as these changes take place
because now we're at the same
vibrational energy that's created them
and so we have to change our attitude
and invite these changes and believe
that something Greater is Coming
you see we are the people that we're
waiting for that's it we're the people
we're waiting for so why not just wake
up so if I can
contribute
to that evolution in some way
if me personally it's not about Joe
dispense I have no interest in that I've
given that up a long time ago what I do
have a fundamental interest in
is
what's possible for human beings and it
should never be about me it should be
about them because there I want them to
experience their own empowerment and you
can't tell me you're too old
you can't tell me you're too sick you
can't tell me you're too overweight or
underweight or had too tough of a past
or your life is too falling you can't
tell me any of those things any longer
can't even tell me you don't even
meditate I never meditated before I've
seen all of every one of those excuses
in every different
genre experience transformation which
means then nobody is so special
to be excluded from this phenomenon
and so I hope that I leave a mark
in some way that Empower people
to no longer believe that they're
limited it's so easy to believe we're
Limited once they realize that they're
empowered and they're unlimited get out
of the way and if they're tempering
those emotions
and they're overcoming those addictions
to those emotions they'll see the hidden
meaning behind all things they'll they
won't necessarily believe everything
they're seeing on the news they'll see
the way it really is because they're no
longer controlled by those emotions
they're at a greater level of energy and
emotions are energy and nobody changes
until they change their energy and when
you change your energy you change
something in your life it's the law so
people are people are doing it we're at
the point where they're doing it and
some of them are becoming it
and when you become it no one can take
it away from you it's yours I believe
that it's not matter that is emitting a
field I think it's the field that
creates matter so when you change the
field you change matter and the science
behind that is very supportive so my
ability to articulate it my research
that I've done since then and the
studies that I've done in additional
education has helped me to be able to
put together a formula in that formula
uh in this present time is is producing
very traumatic changes in people's lives
and health and let's do gratitude
appreciation kindness uh thankfulness
and let's let's start self-regulating
and and we put heart rate monitors on
them to make sure that they were doing
it at 10 minutes a day for three days in
a row right three times a day at the end
of three days three and a half days we
re-measured everything their IGA levels
went up 50 50 that's that means that
their body was really beginning to move
back into balance in homeostasis so
gratitude you know the funny thing about
gratitude is that we're conditioned and
hypnotized into believing that we need a
reason to be grateful no when you get
when you when something happens to you
or something's happening to you when
you're receiving something or you've
received something you feel gratitude
and you say thank you well
when you start to feel gratitude
ahead of the actual experience the
emotional signature of gratitude means
is happening to you it's already
happened to you the Gratitude is the
ultimate state of receiving so you can
take a person
who's been diagnosed with cancer say as
an example they're living in fear and
turning that Battleship around instead
of them surrendering to fear every day
you teach them how to surrender to love
or to gratitude and when they start
self-regulating while their immune
system is going to get stronger we know
that uh and at the same time the thought
of them getting better is going to make
it into the body because
the thought is it can be received by the
feeling of gratitude because the body's
believing believing as the unconscious
mind that it's in a state to receive
that something wonderful is happening to
it so you can begin to program the
autonomic nervous system to work in a
very different way and um and and it
takes it takes practice but um but yes
it's entirely possible and we and we see
we measure this and once you know the
skill on how to do this it's just like
anything else like once you know how to
do it uh you can do it with your eyes
open as well as your eyes closed and you
can turn some of those
very strong chemicals that become we
become like addicts you know there's a
drug you know the arousal of the stress
hormones people start to become very
dependent on them and and they use the
problems and conditions in their life to
reaffirm uh this emotional need to feel
these uh feel these chemicals and that
means they become addicted to the life
they don't even like you know and and if
you can turn on that stress response
just by thought alone you can become
addicted to your own thoughts now this
is this is a challenge for people
because this explains why change is so
hard but by the same means just like an
attic overcoming heroin you're gonna
have some Cravings you know you're gonna
say hey it's been two days since you
suffered I mean come on the hardest part
about change is is not making the same
choices you did the day before and the
moment you decide to make a different
Choice get ready it's going to be
uncomfortable it's going to be
unfamiliar because it's going to be
unpredictable there's going to be some
uncertainty you're you're leaving the
known biologically neurologically
chemically hormonally genetically you're
stepping into a river across a river to
become somebody else and and when people
really start understanding that their
personality creates their personal
reality and your personality is made of
how you think how you act and how you
feel that means then the present
personality who's listening to this show
has created the present personal reality
called her life and if you want to
create a new life a new personal reality
you got to change your personality that
means you got to start thinking about
what you've been thinking about and
changing become aware of your
unconscious habits and behaviors and
notice them and and look at the emotions
that you live by every single day that
keep you connected to the past and
decide when a person can create the
right type of energy the right type of
frequency from the field and there's a
vibrational match between their energy
and whatever they want in their life all
of a sudden they start drawing
experiences to them out of nowhere they
get the phone call hey synchronicity and
synchronicity why because you're
synchronizing your energy
to a possibility in your life now in the
quantum
every thought has a frequency
so when a person has the thought of
their new job
and they can feel the frequency of that
thought it wouldn't be lack it wouldn't
be separation it wouldn't be frustration
the frequency of the thought of a new
job would create the feeling of euphoria
excitement Bliss gratitude
and thoughts tend to be Electric in the
quantum field and feelings tend to be
magnetic and now we teach people how to
create a Wi-Fi signal when when they
connect to the field and they literally
change their energy the thought being
the electrical charge the feeling being
the magnetic charge and how you think
and how you feel is broadcasting energy
now
there's a little bit more that has to
happen because you have to have
coherence in your brain the brain's got
to be very orderly and it's emitting a
field and which it can do with stress
stress stress is static stress you
disconnect because all of your attention
is going on everything physical and
material and you're drawing from this
energy that's surrounding your body and
you're turning into chemistry and now
you're isolated you're separate so we
teach people how to get that brain
coherence going on that hard coherence
is going and coherence is rhythm and
Order and now you have this wi-fi signal
and when there's a vibrational match or
you've synchronized your energy to
synchronicity those serendipities those
coincidences those uh synchronicities
those opportunities start coming to you
now what's the cool part about that it
seems like there's a shortening of time
between the thought of what you want
experience of what you want between
cause and effect when we create from the
field instead of from matter
if we get really good at it
then the feedback that we experience in
our life is letting us know that we're
doing something correctly and when you
start getting the phone call or the
email or the introduction to somebody
and you scratch your head and you go oh
my God I'm the creator of my life and
all of a sudden the next day your belief
in what's possible
grows dramatically so when you sit down
to do it the next time
you get better at it and all of a sudden
more synchronicities start to happen and
so the side effect of it is
and this is what I'm proud of in our
community is that people do the work
they don't they don't do it because they
have to do it they do it because they
don't want the magic to end they want it
they want the synchronicities to be
happening now I would love for you to
share
the mission that you're on and how
people can break past the memory of who
they've been so they can tap into the
potential of who they can be while a
habit is a redundant set of automatic
unconscious thoughts behaviors and
emotions that's acquired through
repetition habit is when you've done
something so many times that your body
actually knows how to do it better than
your conscious mind
it's a habit so people wake up in the
morning and they run through the same
routine every single day
and the routine is mapped out
neurologically in their brain
if they
have the thought of the coffee maker
they make the choice to go over there
they do the thing to make the coffee
they have the experience of drinking it
they feel the emotion associated with it
that becomes a pattern it becomes more
automatic it becomes second nature so we
have a series of these redundant
patterns then and in time we lose our
free will
to a set of programs and the body is
programmed into the predictable future
based on what we've done in the past and
that's how we lose the free will to a
set of programs
so that habituation is the predictable
future and that's the known
and other people wake up in the morning
and they romance their memories of the
past they they think about the problems
that they have in their lives and those
problems are connected to certain people
and certain objects and certain things
at certain times and places and since
the brain is a record of the past the
moment they remember that problem
they're thinking in the past
and every one of those problems has an
emotion that's associated with it
so the moment the person feels unhappy
the moment the person feels fear the
moment the person feels unworthy the
moment the person feels sad now the
body's in the past
because thoughts of the language of the
brain and feelings of the language of
the body and how we think and how we
feel creates our state of being
and so it's that thought and that
feeling it's that image or that memory
and the emotion it's that stimulus and
response
that's conditioning the body to become
mind of that emotion and now the body is
so objective
that it does not know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating the emotion and the emotion
that that person is creating by thought
alone
the bodies reliving the same past
experience over and over again and if we
can't think greater than how we feel or
feelings have become the means of
thinking then we're thinking in the past
and if we believe that our thoughts have
anything to do with our destiny then our
future is going to look a lot like our
past
so that familiar past also is the known
and so what we discovered is that if you
could teach a person
to when their bodies sitting in a
meditation as an example
and it's off schedule
it's used to feeling angry at eight
o'clock in the morning because it
watches the news
the person experiences traffic every day
they get 11 o'clock they check their
emails and they start judging other
people you know there's a there's a set
of familiar emotions that person has
been living by
we discovered that if a person can sit
past
that memory that they can sit past that
emotion that causes them to get aroused
to get frustrated to get impatient
that's the emotion that causes the
person to quit
and they have this conclusion that they
can't meditate or they can't focus or
they have ADD it's a story they tell
themselves about the past
we discovered though that when a person
sits past those
those thoughts that say I can't it's too
hard I'll never change I need a brain
scan there's something wrong with me
it's my mother's fault
and they're curious to see what's on the
other side of that thought when their
body gets aroused and frustrated instead
of giving up and saying
um
I have too many things to do
that they actually learn a way to settle
the body back down into the present
moment and it's David versus Goliath
and every time we can become conscious
that we get emotional we get frustrated
get impatient and we settle the body
down we're executing a will
now that's greater than the program and
the body is no longer the mind the
person is now becoming conscious of
their unconscious self and it takes an
enormous amount of energy
it takes an enormous amount of awareness
to stay present because to stay present
is to be in the unknown
that's when you can't predict the future
and that's not when you're remembering
the past and the unknown in the program
that we have is biological creatures is
a scary place
it's better to run from the unknown to
than to hang out in it we teach
meditation three ways to become familiar
with your old self and to become
familiar with your new self that's what
the word meditation means
familiarization to become familiar with
so we use that model for change so slow
your brain weighs down and get beyond
your analytical mind this meditation and
you teach your body how to do that and
we've discovered a formula that that
simply makes it very easy for people to
do it you practice it you'll get good at
it just like anything else you practice
so so to get beyond the analytical mind
there's another way to reprogram
ourselves and then meditation is really
about getting beyond your body
or disconnecting from your body
disconnecting from your environment and
forgetting about time and that is that
eye of the needle where we begin to make
the most significant changes so we're
data driven you know we're really
looking to see what it is and and when
we see uh brains respond in the same way
it helps me
enormously to teach the material better
and so the more people understand what
they're doing
and the more they understand why they're
doing it the more naturally the how
becomes easier and nothing has left the
conjecture if nothing is left
Superstition or Dogma or even in
spiritual
you know traditional words
new science says the Contemporary
language would demystify that process
and you give new people numerous times
to overcome themselves and numerous
times to connect sooner or later you'll
start watching transformation right
before your eyes and so one of the cool
things that we've discovered is that we
have
so much compelling data to suggest that
you're greater than you think more
powerful than you no more unlimited than
you could ever dream we have compelling
data that suggests that your nervous
system
is the greatest pharmacist in the world
that it makes drugs that work better
than any drug in a drugstore a drug
study is about 18 to 25 percent cause
and effect causality
our data is between 75 and 85 percent
cause and effect this is a person
creating their own Pharmacy of
anti-inflammatories their own Pharmacy
of anti-carcinogenic chemicals their own
Pharmacy of pain relievers who are
seeing this over and over again
so we have this incredible data that
says that this is no longer
pseudoscience this is the real this is
really science the side effect of a
person's transformation
is has changed my belief
in what's possible I have seen people
stand on the stage with stage four
cancers that were in every single organ
in their body that metastasized and and
they have no sign of cancer in their
body and we have data that suggests that
you put the blood of an advanced
meditator and a uterine cancer cell a
pancreatic cancer cell
70 of the mitochondrial function in the
cancer cells diminish the mitochondria
is the energy packets of the cell it's
taking energy out of the cancer cell
works perfect with what we're seeing
with uh the testimonials uh that that
people are telling around the world
we've seen blind people see we've seen
deaf people here we've seen people with
spinal cord injuries walk again we've
seen
ALS change we've seen all kinds of
unbelievable health conditions Changed
by a person simply changing the way they
think the way they act and the way they
feel wake up every day
how bad you want it
how bad do you want in your dream it's
so much easier to forget that Vision
than to remember it right so if you're
going to remember you got to keep it
alive in your mind how do you keep it
alive in your mind you disconnect from
your environment you close your eyes you
play music in the background
you sit your body down and it's got to
pee and it's got to eat and it's got oh
you just just sit down for a few minutes
like training a dog like you stay
when I say it's time to get up we get up
don't be thinking about what's going to
happen in your day you already know
what's going to happen don't think what
happened yesterday you already know that
get in the present moment and say who do
I want to be when I open my eyes
who do I want to be today what would
greatness look like how would I would
one day one shot one lifetime what an
abundant person do I mean rehearse that
with my eyes closed let me remind myself
oh I don't want to be let me remind
myself who do I want to be let's not get
up Lewis until we get in there until we
are to where the tennis ball hits The
Sweet Spot when you go oh I'm ready for
the day now now game on now if you can
maintain that modified State of Mind and
Body the entire day without defaulting
by seeing someone or doing something
stay in that state
the experiment still continues at your
change in your energy doesn't happen in
two days you're not that good right
that's it you're not that good we keep
practicing
people who show up for the 21 weeks in a
row this woman 21 weeks in a row the end
of 21 weeks she knew it
boom her whole life changed boom was it
21 days worth ask her
the experiment she was just changing the
process if you could learn how to rest
your attention in your heart and where
you place your attention is where you
place your energy
regulate your breath start slowing your
breathing down even if you did it for
one minute
you could actually begin to change your
brain waves and you could actually cause
your heart
start functioning more regulation and
more order
if you said okay
I'm going to work with my body
and I'm going to start breathing and I'm
going to start feeling emotions that I
do want to feel
yes it may take you a few minutes to get
there but if you keep practicing it over
and over again
the heart starts producing a very
profound signal it starts to produce an
external magnetic field it's it's it's
measurable
so now you have a coherent brain which
means you can get very intentional
and you have a coherent heart which
means you can feel the emotions of your
future before it happens
somehow you have this broadcasting of
this wi-fi signal uh and the Brain tends
to be electrical in nature so it's sends
out an electrical charge into the field
the heart is the magnetic charge it's
what draws things to us
it's the it's the magnetic field and now
you actually by changing the way you
think and the way you feel you're
changing the signal in the field then if
you're able to maintain that state
for an extended period of time I say
something magical is going to happen in
your life
something unusual some unknown
experience is going to occur if you keep
thinking the same way and feeling the
same way your life should stay the same
this is a person who came into our event
with severe anxiety take a look at the
front of the brain
most of the brain in
Delta and Theta and Alpha and Beta And
even high beta the blue represents that
there's no energy in the frontal lobe
now frontal lobe is the CEO of the brain
it's the symphony leader if the boss of
the symphony leader is no longer leading
the orchestra or leading the community
the rest of the brain has a very strong
tendency to move out of disorder just
like any organization
three days of meditation
you can see that there's very little red
in the brain
if there's no blue and there's no red it
represents normal
now you can see that the certain amount
of symmetry that's taking place on the
right side there represents that the
person's in a more coherent and balanced
coherent brainwave State another person
comes to our event severe anxiety you
can see all that red in the brain and
high beta represents a lot of vigilance
and a lot of anxiety three days later
after the event you don't see any red in
there this person healed themselves of
anxiety as well
a person with Parkinson's disease
Parkinson's disease is deficiency and
dopamine in the brain when there's not
enough dopamine in the brain the upper
motor neurons can't communicate with
each other when there's an aberrant
motor function that's taking place in
the neurons of the brain it sends a very
signal to the body and people
experience involuntary Tremors with
Parkinson's disease
three days of meditation
look at this person's brain it
represents way more coherence and much
less
overactive brain activity every time you
learn something new you make new
Connections in your brain that's what
learning is learning is forging new
synaptic connections
and as you begin to leave imprints in
your neurological tissue as a result of
your interaction in the environment
the next thing is that you're going to
have an opportunity then to apply that
information
to personalize it to demonstrate it
and a certain people group of people
will get their behaviors to match their
intentions to get their actions equal to
their thoughts they'll step out into the
unknown
and we'll try it and when they do
they'll have a new experience
and experience then enriches the brain
reorganizing more circuits than what you
understood physiologically
but the moment those neurons string into
place
the brain makes a chemical and that
chemical is called a feeling or an
emotion
and the moment you feel Unlimited
the moment you feel like a patient
parent the moment you feel abundant the
moment you feel free
now you are teaching your body
chemically
to understand what your mind is
intellectually understood
so we can say knowledge is for the mind
and experiences for the body
and in that moment you're beginning to
embody the truth of that philosophy of
that theory and you're literally
signaling new genes in new ways and you
are rewriting your biological program
but if you've done it once
it must mean you can do it again
and if you can repeat any experience
over and over again you are going to
neurochemically condition your mind and
body to begin to work as one
and when you've done something so many
times that the body now knows how to do
it as well as the mind now it's becoming
innate in you
it's second nature it's easy it's
familiar
it's who you are
as a matter of fact you've practiced it
so many times that you don't even have
to consciously think about it because
it's becoming a subconscious program
so our job
is to go from philosopher
to initiate to master
from knowledge to experience to wisdom
from mind to body to Soul
from thinking to doing to being to
learning it with your head practicing it
with your hands and knowing it by heart
the whole purpose of meditation is to
get beyond the analytical mind and what
separates the conscious mind from the
subconscious mind is the analytical mind
and so we'll talk about that in a minute
but we teach people how to create
coherent brains and of course we also
teach them and they understand that when
they're resentful or they're impatient
or they're frustrated their heart also
beats incoherently as well so then is it
possible then to train them to regulate
their autonomic nervous system by
changing their brain waves and by
changing their heart coherence so then
they can begin to transform themselves
and transform matter and that's kind of
the model that we use next slide quick
little overview on brain waves here look
at the top one there it says beta brain
waves you can see they're pretty fast
your brain's job is to create meaning or
coherence between what's going on in
your outer world and what's going on in
your inner world most people function in
beta brainwave patterns when they're
awake and they wake up in their morning
and their brain starts making serotonin
they start to use their senses and
they're integrating everything through
their senses and their brains trying to
process all that information into
meaning so they're sitting there feeling
pain they're tired they're hungry they
have the light on they're doing a few
things and the brain's got to deal with
all that information so brain waves in
the thinking brain are pretty quick when
you close your eyes and you eliminate
your external environment as an example
your brain kind of slows down in brain
waves because it's processing less
information so now you're in Alpha and
Alpha instead of the outer World being
more real the inner world starts
becoming more real when your body falls
asleep and your mind is awake you move
into what's called Theta brainwave
patterns that's a good place to be
because if you've conditioned your body
to be the mind then your body's asleep
and your mind is awake that means it's
no longer the mind then you can fall
right into some pretty quick changes and
reprogram those automatic programs Delta
of course is restorative sleep and we
won't have time to get into gamma but I
call gamma super Consciousness or super
awareness that's when the brain is
aroused but instead of because of some
predators some threat in the environment
the brain is aroused because the
sympathetic nervous system is switched
on and it's releasing energy instead of
out of the body up into the brain and
the person's really has all their
attention on the inner experience I'm
curious uh why is it that as humans we
default to this fear-based thinking it's
so hard wired in us as a species that's
lived in survival for
for so many thousands of years and in
survival you know fear is really
adaptive if you want to survive that
chemical Rush is telling you that
there's danger or there's a threat and
to run from that danger or stay off and
face the conflict you know that was kind
of the model of of survival of the
fittest so when we perceive the problems
and challenges in our life and it evokes
fear right like and because we don't
think we can control it or we can't
predict it or it looks like things could
get worse that's what turns on that
primitive nervous system that puts you
in a state of alarm in a state of
arousal and we're just been bred for
thousands of years to to live in
survival and turns out that when we we
live in those States for extended
periods of time it has biological
effects on the health of the body but
but to the person the arousal then
becomes something stimulating
so without knowing it they they start
relying on their response to stimulate
their body to keep it awake to keep it
alive and then they can think about
their problems in the same exact way and
produce that arousal and keep the body
in a state of a you know state of
emergency
turns out it gets a little addictive
after a while and and then we start
using the people and problems in our
lives to reaffirm that addiction to that
emotion and we're addicted to a a life a
miserable life we don't even like you
know and that's why change becomes so
hard because that becomes the known that
becomes the familiar and you're always
you know anticipating the next moment
but that's a default it's hardwired in
the human being because survival was
adaptive at one point but fast forward
to now and and the conditions and are no
longer T-Rex chasing you they're just a
little bit more complex and it requires
a lot of uncertainty and a lot of
unpredictability and that's exactly what
creates the hormones of stress so our
response to the environment has to
change and that's what we practice doing
because when you're no longer responding
to the same conditions in the same
emotional way I think when you master
your emotions you master your Creations
things start to change in your life I
have a question regarding the use of
cell phones and how it generates
dopamine and how is it in some way
affects our
meditations our ability to meditate
excellent question
the question was to repeat it I want to
know the effects of cell phones
on our brains and how it affects our
dopamine levels and and you know I I
raised three kids and
you know kids use technology and I was
saying this when I was talking to some
of you this morning over a cup of coffee
that that if your children are using
cell phones for information basically we
are information that's all we are
and they're they're they're accessing
information the way they do and they're
using their cell phones in all kinds of
ways for stimulation
there should be a period of time where
they were able to set it down just like
for you
and if you can't break your romance with
your cell phone
then it owns you would you agree
because that's what keeps you connected
to networks socially that kind of social
Consciousness is is is is is is
maintained through networks and
it feeds us because we love tribe We
Love Culture we love connection but it's
it's got to be done with discernment
so what happens for people is
if they if they can't break from it and
go from a narrow Focus to a broad Focus
like get out in nature go hike go get on
a boat I mean open your focus and look
at the sunset you don't think that
creates Alpha in your brain it does
nature does that the resonance the
human's constant is the exact 7.8
frequency of Alpha Brain waste in
training us
to connection
so when when they've done the research
on on cell phones the video gaming to
start with they said to these kids Hey
listen um here's how it's going to go
you guys want to make some money what do
you think the kids said yeah let's make
some money yeah I said okay we're gonna
get you involved in a video game
and then we're going to ring a bell
and you have five seconds to stop if you
stop in five seconds we'll give you a
dollar and we're just going to go as
long as you remember how long it went do
you know that none of the children none
of them were able to stop
that's how that's how addictive it is
so the research shows then
that when you begin to blow somebody up
or you shoot someone or you get a text
you know that's important text to you
there's a release of dopamine in your
brain the pleasure chemical reward
chemical is released but if you're
overdoing it and you're playing a lot of
video gaming and you're blowing
something something up or blowing
someone up or breaking through some
level or doing something the reward
systems are being activated in your
brain and you start releasing too much
dopamine all at once
and that burst of dopamine into the
brain is more than the receptor sites
have to handle it you understand what
I'm saying come on
so then the over amount of dopamine is
not being absorbed by those receptors
The receptors closed down it's too much
they become desensitized it's like
living with a spouse that always yells
at you they got to yell a little louder
to get your attention the next time you
need a little bit more now to turn it on
the next time does that make sense so
then the pleasure cam the pleasure
centers start recalibrating to a higher
and higher level it takes more now to
turn the money into a bigger burst to
get them stimulated
are you with me still
so the pleasure centers start
recalibrating to such a high level that
now the person needs the game
needs the phone to feel something
to make that feeling because in the
absence of any stimulation
they experience a loss of pleasure
you understand what I'm saying
they become desensitized to pleasure so
a walk with your dog
don't tell a kid to go see their
grandmother
watch a sunset just way too slow
they're over stimulated are you with me
still
and that's called adhedonia you can't
find pleasure from anything
at hedonia is it possible then if your
thoughts can make you sick your thoughts
can make you well
and that's exactly what our research
shows you keep thinking the same way you
keep making the same choices you keep
doing the same things you keep having
the same experiences and reacting to the
same conditions with the same emotions
for the most part your genes in your
brain and everything is going to stay
the same in your blood values because
you're the same so then the process of
thinking differently making different
choices doing different things creating
different experiences and feeling
different emotions if you do that for
seven days
you have significant changes that take
place on a cellular level on your brain
in in just about every part of your
biology because you're you're you're
making those changes our discoveries
really have to do with showing people
that their nervous system is the
greatest Pharmacy in the world that it
that it makes chemicals that work better
than any drug we can say that with with
such certainty when a person moves into
into these states
the Practical part of it all the time is
is the daily practice people in our work
that do this work they do it really
because they understand what they're
doing and why they're doing it and when
you combine the what and the why the how
tends to get easier I love what you said
about the nervous system being sort of
the greatest Pharmacy because I don't
think we know the power of our bodies
the power of our health the power of
coherence yeah well that's a great
question because the people who live in
stress are living in survival as they
try to control and predict everything
that takes place in their life every
person every object every circumstance
has a neurological Network in the brain
and the arousal of the stress hormones
shifts our attention very quickly to all
these elements in our lives and our
brains literally start firing out of
order they start firing like a lightning
storm and the clouds very incoherently
and networks of neurons start working
separately from one another they come
departmentalize when the brain is
incoherent we're incoherent when the
brain isn't working right we're not
working right the heart which is now
pumping an enormous amount of blood
against the closed system the the
arteries aren't you're not running
you're not fighting so the pressure
against the heart causes the heart to be
very incoherently and in that state
energy goes down in the heart
incoherence creates a loss of energy
both in the heart and the brain so that
kind of dysregulation that takes place
in the nervous system begins to send
very incoherent messages through the
autonomic nervous system to all the
cells and tissues and organs in the body
and the brain is now really over focused
you know when you're in stress you're
really thinking a lot you're thinking
about the same thing over and over again
it's looping and that looping actually
within that emotional state is actually
driving your brain to become more and
more analytical and moving into very
high brainwave States you're narrowing
your focus on something and that's what
we do when the arousal of stress causes
us to pinpoint our focus on a person on
circumstance on a problem a thought
whatever it is that that cycle then is
continuously causing the body to move
out of balance just because the brain
and the heart are sending signals to the
body that are that the cells don't
understand it's not coherent that's
autonomic dysregulation how you think
and how you feel creates your state of
being
and you're thinking the same thoughts
that are creating the same feelings and
same emotions and those emotions are
influencing your thoughts would you
agree then you're signaling that same
gene over and over again and if genes
are responsible for the structure and
the function of the body and you keep
selecting and instructing the same gene
you're going to wear that Gene out
yes or no yes just like gears in your
car picking a facts of a facts of a
facts of a fax or a copy of a copy of a
copy sooner or later it's going to lose
its detail yes or no that's exactly what
happens to the body the body begins to
break down because those proteins are
responsible for your physiology for your
structure so then if immune cells make
immune proteins
and you're living in fear every single
day
you're living in anger and resentment
and impatience every single day then
you're signaling the same gene in the
same way yes or no
and if you keep doing that for a period
of time sooner or later you're going to
program that Gene and all of a sudden
the body is going to get unhealthy yes
or no
and look you know people say well I did
my meditation
three days and nothing happened
but I tell them how long did it take you
to create that condition tell me
so then if meditation means to become
familiar with
you got to become more familiar with the
thoughts behaviors and emotions of your
future then familiar with the thoughts
and behaviors emotions of your past yes
or no
so then if you keep firing and wiring
the same circuits in your brain
installing the circuits the hardware
becomes a software program and it gets
easier to think in unlimited ways it's
easier to act like a wealthy person it
becomes easier than to cultivate the
emotions of your future instead of the
emotions of your past the stronger the
emotion you feel the more you pay
attention to the person or the problem
that's our Vital life force we're giving
to that person or that problem well and
then we're telling the story 50
different times to all of our friends
can you believe this
reaffirming reaffirming the same feeling
over and over again and the body's
actually moving out of balance more and
more every time we do that there we're
actually draining the body from energy
right so so it makes sense then that
when people do this a long time then
they they can't feel anything else but
anger fear pain suffering guilt shame
anxiety the competition Envy jealousy
and security resentment those are all
derived from the hormones of stress you
know and and psychology calls those
normal human States Of Consciousness
those are Altered States of
consciousness
so so it makes sense then that if those
emotions make us feel one way because
the body is always out of balance we
decided to do an experiment we took 117
people and we said listen
we want you to stop feeling those
emotions just for
three times a day for 15 minutes we're
just going to practice feeling a
different emotion yeah I know but I
can't feel it I know I know you can't
feel it now because you're really good
at feeling that other stuff but if we
work with you just work with us turns
out
10 15 minutes of gratitude two or three
times a day
their immune system strengthened by 50
percent they they made the most robust
immunoglobulin you know immunoglobulin a
which is the primary defense against
bacteria and viruses the body's getting
a boost there's an internal Army now and
it turns out that when that occurs a lot
of pain inflammation goes away and a lot
of immune mediated conditions from
cancer all the way to food allergies and
everything in between so so we found out
that your thoughts could actually make
you well I'll spend a month of my own
personal journey in practicing surrender
like what is surrender how much more
surrender could I surrender in my life
in my meditations I'll work on that you
know for a period of time I'll work on
other times laying down after a
meditation and keep working on relaxing
my body more and more while I work on
staying awake because I think that's the
door right so I'll practice that for a
period of time so that when I get back
into my work
uh in my regular meditations those
things are enhanced right and the breath
is another thing that you can practice
as part of your whole meditation
practice
that we get good at whatever we practice
right I mean that's just the way it is
so so I just wanted that to be a
contribution
uh to the community for those people who
want to improve their skill
of doing the breath so let's say that
they practice that and they okay this
time every day before I go to bed even
though I'm tired I'm going to practice
this thing so that in my morning
meditations my breath becomes more more
enhanced or more enriched and so
um it's just something you can as a tool
you can take and and put into your
practice so
um I try to So when you say do a
meditation that has the breath in it
along with other things in that
meditation you'll be more proficient at
doing the breath instead of resisting it
you'll actually enjoy it and we have
people you know we can ask them to do
the breath we can have their brain
hooked up and we they I can tell you I
can say to that person would you go into
high gamma for the scientists and they
can do it in five minutes because why
they practice it enough times that
they're good at it for all my listeners
what's step one so we're not going to
take them from
very egocentric and physically oriented
to the end mystical Journey overnight
but what's step one that you suggested
and recommend that everyone gets on
tomorrow when they wake up
look I mean it's really simple I don't
have a problem with you putting your
attention on your body I think you
should I think you should really take
care of your temple and make sure that
you treat it really well but there's a
time when you have to get Beyond it and
if you can't be on get Beyond it then um
that that's your identity so so I think
that people come to this work for many
different reasons some people come for
health conditions or diseases people
come because they want a new life people
come because they want answers but I
don't really care what a person comes
for because ultimately when they start
connecting their values change and they
start feeling differently and they
change and and they still have a great
body and they still have a healthy body
but in addition to that they have a
healthy mind and and so um I think
really a great start for people is to
wake up in the morning and ask
themselves a simple question what is the
greatest ideal of myself that I can be
today what is the greatest expression of
myself and really sit down
and decide who they want to be when they
open their eyes and just the act of
closing your eyes and thinking about it
and making choices differently than you
typically do and and rehearsing them and
actually follow through and doing them
is going to lead you to A Whole New Life
over time so it's not that mystical
because the mystical is the side effect
it's the phenomenon of this work the the
real thing is to to have a a more
profoundly enriched life where you're in
it and you love it and you want more of
it that's uh that's what I want for
everybody and for some people it may be
the mystical for some people it may be a
million dollars or ten million dollars I
don't care I just want them to create it
just whatever you want just get busy
creating it and prove to yourself really
how powerful you are and and um we've
got a lot of people doing it I think
this particular time in history uh
people are waking up to possibilities
and you have to admit that when you
become aware of something that didn't
exist before
uh there's a change in Consciousness and
so I think people because of information
at this current time in history are just
more informed than because they're more
informed they're more conscious of
possibilities and and
and so
when you take a group of people and you
give them sound scientific information
and as you as you said science to me is
the Contemporary language of mysticism
that that science can demystify the
mystical
and if you can combine a Quantum model
of reality that says that somehow
you're connected to everything that your
thoughts have an effect on the nature of
reality and if mind is an important
element of that then we better study and
understand what mind is so if you can
combine some Neuroscience some
neuroendocrinology with some
psychoneuroimmunology the Mind Body
Connection in epigenetics that says that
you're not doomed by your genes to be a
certain way your entire life that you
could actually change your Gene
Expressions I wanted to listen to the
questions that people asked and the
questions were okay you create your
reality I get it how do you do it
I thought it was a brilliant question
next question is okay your personality
creates your personal reality your
personality is made by how you think how
you act and how you feel if I want to
change my personal reality I got to
change my personality nothing changes in
my life to life change how do we change
why is it so hard to change and then the
last question was what do you do
and so we started teaching these events
you know around the world and and giving
people some tools and basic neuroscience
and epigenetics and brain waves and
electromagnetism building a model and
you know at the end of an event people
would say I I feel a little better you
know I have a better sense of well-being
but we weren't seeing any dramatic
changes in people's health and then it
took about a year
and we just I was running these events
and every time I'd run an event
someone's say can you do another one
somebody did a more evolved version and
then we did another revolvers and then I
said I don't know anything else
I don't know anything else and then I
started having profound mystical
experiences and that changed my view of
the world dramatically and I remember at
one event
this woman with Ms sitting in a
wheelchair after one meditation stood up
out of that throne and started dancing
around
and when I saw that happening I knew
something had to be taking place
inwardly in her in other words
there must have been some Gene
regulation
that happen as a result of her inner
process and that's when everything
changed for me that's when I got a team
of scientists and neuroscientists and
biologists and partnered with heart math
Institute we started building this model
of understanding of 18 000 brain scans
now
the thousands and thousands of HR V
measurements we got Gene testing that's
done telomere testing that's not immune
regulation you know thousands of
different metabolites at this point I I
wanted to see if that person's
subjective experience of whatever that
was could be calibrated objectively and
once we understood that information can
we teach transformation better
and if you can do it and capture that
information and teach transformation
better you can shorten the distance
between really the thought and the
experience of what a person wants and
and I think that the science has become
the Contemporary language to demystify
that process and once you use tradition
or culture religion
divide an audience but science creates
community and people want to use that as
a language now it's the Contemporary
language you communicate with your
patients in terms of science I mean how
many people here run a clinic and the
first thing you say to a patient when
they start talking about their health
condition is that's not true I used to
say that every day that's not true that
is not the truth
so then that information then that
people are beginning to understand is is
theoretical and philosophical and now
there's too many testimonials I mean
we're just talking backstage every
single day we have something that
challenges my belief
the challenge is my belief and what's
possible and when I see the scientists
running the same
study over and over again
he's running the same study five times
over again then changing the study and
running it a different way and getting
the same result I know he's changing his
belief right there I know she's changing
her belief they're looking for something
else to occur and actually cousin this
is new information it's a discovery I've
got
small field of vision
very I have no peripheral vision in my
right eye not being able to see on this
side at all
and then today when I was walking it
took me a long time to get into it and
then I thought okay I'm just going to
probably halfway through I thought I'm
just going to walk with purpose
and walk like a person that can see and
then I can't remember the rest of it
until I got to the end and then when I
was walking back
there was like the trees around and not
flat
and I can see my hand
and that's it that's just a little taste
sister now is she beautiful
isn't she is can you relate with her
she's not like a movie star she's not
buffed you know she doesn't look she
doesn't have the perfect everything that
people think it has to be that way she
looks just like you and you can relate
with her yes and because you're looking
at evidence this is evidence she has
depth perception now she just decided
she made up her mind to go all in to
walk as somebody that was that had sight
she got so wrapped up in the action that
she forgot about herself she's walking
right into her future self she's walking
right in she's becoming her future self
that's part of your dream is it not she
walked into her future she came back to
her senses her senses were working
better
and all she did was get a biological
upgrade by getting Beyond herself you
better be walking like anything's
possible you better become the very
person you want to be and get so
involved in it did you forget about
space and time and that's exactly what
happened to her she unified with the
unified field she overcame some aspect
of her limited self to join their
greater self she lost herself in nothing
she lost herself in the act and became
something else when she came back to her
senses she took a piece of that energy
with her and she got a biological
upgrade all she had to do was become
that person she's a different
personality right in front of you than
the personality that started this day
today she's somebody else and it's
reflected in her biology and all she did
was make up her mind to do it meditation
the actual translation of the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so the first thing you have to do is you
have to become conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to notice
your automatic habits and behaviors and
you have to become aware of your
emotions that keep you anchored to the
past and if you can become so conscious
of the one unconscious states of mind
and body that they would never slip by
your conscious awareness again you're
becoming familiar with the old self so
you don't return then of you begin to
think about new ways of being being
defined by a vision
plan your behaviors review them in your
mind now if you keep doing that over and
over again nerve cells that fire
together wire together you begin to
become familiar with a new state of mind
at the same time if you can emotionally
cultivate your inspiration your joy Your
Enthusiasm ahead of the experience by
repeating that over and over again
cultivating that state it's going to
begin to become familiar to you so then
the process of change then requires
unlearning and relearning breaking the
habit of the old self Reinventing a new
self
pruning synaptic connections as we say
in neuroscience and sprouting new
connections unmerizing emotions that are
stored in the body then here's the key
reconditioning the body to a new mind
into a new emotion it's literally moving
from your past to your future it's
losing your mind and creating a new one
and so then when you begin to understand
that in the in that process it's going
to feel a little bit unfamiliar
uncomfortable and if you can relax into
that instead of going back to the past
continuously invest in your future
sooner or later it'll begin to become
easier and easier and easier and all of
a sudden when you least expect it
something amazing is going to happen in
your life and when that event begins to
occur you're going to pay attention to
what you did inside of you now to
produce the effect outside of you and
that's called human empowerment and
there isn't a person in the world that's
excluded from this equation there's time
little calcium carbonate crystals in the
pineal gland that are stacked up on top
of each other and the human being
rhombohedrons
and they're stacked up on top of each
other and the research says
that it has piezoelectric properties
what does that mean I looked it up
when you apply a mechanical stress
to these crystals the mechanical stress
begins to create an electrical charge in
the crystal
and the compression begins to polarize
the ends of the crystal with a positive
charge and a negative charge and when
you polarize the crystal with a positive
charge and a negative charge what do you
have
a magnet
okay
and all of a sudden as you compress
those crystals the mechanical stress
creates an electrical field
and that field actually expands until
the crystals can't stretch any longer
and then the field reverses
and when the field reverses the field
actually exerts a pressure against the
crystals again
that causes the crystals to expand and
the next thing you know you have a
little radio receiver
how many people understand
and you switch on the brain's radio
receiver
and now the brain can tune in
the frequencies
beyond the census
and that is the mystical gland
and the research says it's a transducer
how do I know
I looked it up
I didn't go on social I looked it up
transducer like a television antenna
that's what it said
taking energy and information in one
form and turning it into pictures and
images meaning
and that's why it's called the third eye
because you have an inner Vision that's
more real than the outer world the brain
now is picking up information from the
field and it's transducing it into
profound imagery a mystical
transcendental moment and we do the
breath
when you finish that breath I'm going to
ask you to finish it right on that
pineal gland that's your target
and I'm going to ask you to hold your
breath
now this is not torture
I'm not asking you to hold your breath
to see how long you can hold your breath
if you're thinking about how long you're
holding your breath you're not doing it
I want your attention as you hold your
breath I'm going to ask you to lift this
up pull this in lock this down
straighten your spine drop down and pump
and squeeze a little bit more and I just
want you to keep squeezing and pushing
that fluid right up against that Target
there or
I'll say Exile and then you feel and we
go get it again
I don't feel like it is not going to do
anything
I'm too old nothing will happen you got
to leave that behind you you got to get
lost in the act
and when that energy moves I have had it
happen
thousands of times
it is big
it's not like oh I'm an energy worker
it's not like that
it's like holy heck
it's a train that's moving
and it goes right up to the brain
and that energy is being released in the
brain and the Brain goes into those
gamma brainwave patterns very high gamma
brainwave patterns we know according to
the epigenetic model that the
environment signals the gene without a
doubt
and end products of an experience in the
environment is an emotion
so by people sustaining elevated
heart-centered emotions and getting
really good at doing it with our eyes
open they're signaling genes ahead of
their environment and genes make
proteins and proteins are responsible
for the structure and function of the
body and the expression of proteins is
the expression of life now when the
person understands if I live by this
emotional state every single day and my
body's so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating this emotion yes and the
emotion that I'm fabricating by thought
alone and they assign meaning to the ACT
I'm doing this because I want to Signal
new genes the moment they assign meaning
to the ACT they switch on their
prefrontal cortex and they get greater
value from the act that means then they
start noticing that their pain levels
start to diminish that their range of
motion starts to improve that they're
sleeping better
uh that they feel more calm and more
present the moment they notice those
changes that are happening now their
meditation becomes even more thoughtful
even more powerful because now they're
noticing the effects of them themselves
the cause they're not waiting for their
healing
to feel wholeness and gratitude they
understand that feeling wholeness and
gratitude is actually creating their
healing which is a Quantum principle
which you in the quantum you got to feel
it first to experience before you
experience it so but but if you don't
know that then you're waiting for your
out of something in your outer World to
Change or waiting for something to
change in your biology in order for you
to feel gratitude or feel whole and
that's just the old model of of cause
and effect the the quantum model is
about causing an effect
the challenge is that there's a period
of going from the old self to the new
self that is that unknown place where
you're always looking and when the
moment you're looking you're separate
from it so it takes training it takes
practice and we know that if a person
immerses themselves in a retreat for
three days or seven days and we give
them the the knowledge and we use
science as that model when we combine
quantum physics with neuroscience and
neuroendocrinology and psychon or
Immunology in uh epigenetics we we in my
electromagnetism we give them that
knowledge and information and if
knowledge is power knowledge about
yourself is self-empowerment so on the
mind can rest and and the mind can
actually understand what it's doing and
why it's doing and when you understand
the what and the why the how it gets
easier and doesn't matter how sick you
are it doesn't matter how old you are
how in shape you are how out of shape
you are if you ever meditated before
we've got the data to show that none of
those things actually matter it's just
really understanding the process and
giving people
numerous opportunities to overcome
themselves and in beta brainwave
patterns you tend to pay more attention
to your outer world that's healthy
so then when you're aroused though by
the hormones of stress now you move into
that high beta brainwave pattern and now
you're overly analytical
in fact you're trying to figure things
out
and when you're when you're aroused by
those stress hormones and the emotions
of those hormones are a record of the
past our research shows that when you're
analyzing some problem
some condition something about yourself
within that emotion you're making your
brain worse because you're driving it
further into higher beta brainwave
patterns because as you think about the
problem you start producing more of the
chemistry and you start analyzing and
all of a sudden you get caught in this
Loop how many people understand and
people stay stuck
for many many many years in that high
beta brainwave pattern and now the
Reliant on something outside of them to
change that state whether it's a drug a
drink whatever it is a computer game
something to help them to to change
their internal state
when you give people sound scientific
information
and science is the Contemporary language
of mysticism it's science that
demystifies the mystical
and once they can understand it and they
can learn it they're forging new
Connections in their brain that's what
learning is
if they have a model of understanding
that they can
theoretically begin to
process in their mind and it makes sense
to them
the research shows that if you don't
review that information that you've
learned if you don't repeat it if you
don't think about it over and over again
the circuits that you've just forged
were weakened and they'll prune apart
and you won't remember so if learning is
making use and not the connections then
remembering is maintaining them so if a
person can explain that to somebody and
they can
build that model with someone else and
they can explain that model they're
beginning to install the neurological
Hardware in their brain in preparation
for the experience and as I said the
more they understand what they're doing
the more they understand why they're
doing it the how tends to get easier and
they can assign meaning to the process
so we started
putting people through this process and
then I thought well if we can set up the
conditions in the environment and give
them the proper instructions
a certain percentage of the people will
get their behaviors to match their
intentions look at their actions equal
to the thoughts when they get their mind
and body working together they'll have a
new experience in that experience that
enriches the philosophical circuits in
their brain and the moment those neurons
begin to organize into networks the
brain makes a chemical and that chemical
is called a feeling or an emotion so the
payoff from every experience is that
chemical signature called an emotion and
so the moment they started to feel
empowered the moment they started to
feel more unlimited the more they
started to feel free the more they start
to feel grateful from some experience
they were teaching their body chemically
to understand what their mind is and
intellectually understood I started to
realize that knowledge is for the mind
and experiences for the body
and I started to see that people started
to embody the truth of that Philosophy
from the experience and that was the
information that began to select and
instruct new genes
and they started to change on a very
basic level I see your passion you're
passionate about what you're doing your
passion in your work is really tangible
and
um do you see it as a mission are you on
a mission how do you see it unfolding in
the future and
um what is the future of this Mission
look like in respect of your
um growing worldwide Community your
scientific research I know it's a lot
and the potential for personal
transformation for me I I do have a
passion and I do have a mission and that
I believe that in order to transform a
culture to transform a community to
transform the world you have to start
with the individual
and so my passion and my interest is
human change human potential human
transformation and um for me that
mission is I believe that if we can
teach people
uh how to heal themselves
[Music]
how to heal others if we can teach them
a new way of life in terms of what is
possible
I think if we can produce outcomes in
seeing people that that demonstrate that
in some way I think it does change
Consciousness so I'm very Mission driven
and I think that the highest form of
motivation is a mission-driven
motivation when you when you have a
vision that's bigger than you and so
um I'm happy to say that that's what
gets me up in the morning that's what
gets my team up in the morning uh that
when we celebrate someone's personal
change or personal transformation
personal healing
um I think that inspires us to want to
do more of it so
um
that type of personal conviction that
comes with that mission means that every
day you have to get your behaviors to
match that Vision or that mission that
intention
um I think it's important to navigate
with a sense of Ethics a sense of
morality uh and and and to show people
um that you can demonstrate this work by
being examples so how do I see it
affecting our growing Community uh
I think there has to be an emergent
Consciousness on the planet that it
shows people that there's another way of
living and so I'm so proud of our
community because we're doers we do the
work we practice uh being creators of
our lives and I think it's important to
show people in the world what love does
that if we want forgiveness in the world
we have to show people what forgiveness
looks like if we want to heal the world
then we have to heal ourselves if we
want peace in the world we have to show
the world what peace looks like we have
to demonstrate that and I think because
an emerging Consciousness comes out of
that
Consciousness is an awareness and the
awareness that there's another way to
live and another way to thrive I think
gives people permission to to believe
that it's possible so we have this
emergent Community you know this this
emerging Consciousness that really is
about being at cause in their life
instead of being at effect and I think
that each individual
uh in our community is a representation
of the whole so if you're working on
overcoming your fear or your pain or
your past or trauma that's happened to
you if you're working on overcoming a
health condition
um and I'm working on my own thing and
if we're truly truly on that that path I
what what comes out of that is human
goodness most of us tell the story of
our past in a negative sense of how it's
held us back
um
millions of times of our life as opposed
to the story of the future of what we
want to create or who we want to become
yeah listen again you tell that story in
the latest research on memory says that
memory is creative that in fact fifty
percent of that story you embellish
people make up that story let me tell
you why they make up that story because
they excuse themselves for the fact that
they haven't been able to change
since that event they'll have to make it
sound worse than it really was to make
it harder to grow and change so that
they can reaffirm their limited sense of
their inability to change so then that
story becomes more and more of a story
and it's less of the truth because you
got to work yourself up into a state
there were lions and tigers and they
were right you know they were
helicopters snowstorms didn't matter if
he was firing bullets the worst thing
you could possibly imagine and then
you've got to feel that emotion right
and then you look at this oh yeah it
must have been really bad now that's
that's your identity now that's your
identity
the more you hold on to that identity of
the past the harder it is to become who
you want to be in the future well here's
here's to answer the other part of your
question when we started talking
how do you get that person out of their
past yeah well we need a week it's not
going to happen and it doesn't happen
overnight no I want them to come right
up against their fear I want them to
come right up against their doubt I want
them to come up against the point where
they're going to give up and quit and
they're going to sit there and nobody
else is giving up and quitting and
they're going to go all in more and
they're going to start believing what
there's something on the other side of
that emotion they're going to believe
that there's something past the story of
their past because they're stretching
themselves out of the known and it takes
a tremendous amount of awareness
repetition information model building
sharing understanding experiencing to
finally have a person get to the point
where they just let go and when they do
the body's liberated from the past and
there's a release of energy and we now
know that there's a formula to teach
people how to do that in fact we're
getting so good at it that the first two
days day and a half sometimes one day in
certain groups of a week-long event
is about retiring that past finishing it
you know this is when the story ends
this is when they get over it now the
next five days
the person's ready to create a new
future and they're not going to have a
problem teaching their body what it
feels like to be in love with life to
feel like all their needs are met that
they're free they are going to fall in
love with it and they are going to begin
to Signal new genes they're going to be
interchanged to brain circuitry their
brain chemistry their immune system
their gene expression they're telling me
is it's all going to happen they're
they're more of that future self and and
they're they're headed to a future now
here's the deal though you got to be
able to sustain that state when you
return back to your life that's the name
of the game you got to be able right you
got to bring the game into your life now
and no person no circumstance no
condition in your life would cause you
to feel the old way again because the
moment you started feeling victimized
the moment you started feeling angry you
just returned to the old self you
disconnected from the energy of your
future and you're back to the energy of
your past we'd love you to speak into
how when we find coherence when we find
alignment between brain and heart then
we can we can Steward whatever reality
we want to us in in record time yeah so
one of the things that we we do is we we
when you're agitated at someone on a
zoom call
and you know you're doing the
and you're thinking about five ways to
throttle them you know I'm chilling but
you get the idea you're aroused by
something that knocks you out of balance
and you're sitting there you know your
heart's beating against the closed
system
it's pumping blood but you're not
running you're not fighting you're not
hiding and it starts it starts creating
problems the heart starts beating out of
order out of rhythm
and so we discovered when we started
seeing teaching people
how to place their attention on their
heart when they where you place your
attention is where you place your and
out of all the things that you feel with
you know what I'm talking about with
your body
we ask people to feel with nothing but
their heart
and where you place your attention is
where you place your energy and we
we started seeing we've started hooking
up the heart the the E CG monitors with
the brain and every time the heart would
flux into coherence you would see this
wave of alpha it's just this beautiful
coherent wave of alpha heart was telling
the brain create and Alpha is a creative
state and when we're an alpha we see in
pictures we've seen images or imagine
when we're in beta we're thinking we're
analyzing it's the voice in your head so
we saw that when the person dropped into
their heart really well there was this
kind of wave of information that that
went to the brain caused the brain to
become very coherent and was always
after the heart doing it was in that
state
and so we started realizing that the
heart was the creative Center it was
it's when we move out of these first
three centers and we move into our heart
when we move into that Center The Heart
starts telling the brain it starts
informing the brain so we started
building instruments with in with our
brain scientists and our in our
scientific team
where we could actually see how this
kind of phenomena worked and so
when a person starts putting their
attention in their heart we start seeing
this uh low frequency this very low
frequency in the heart that's only
indigenous to the heart start to fill up
like a gas tank just the person is just
putting their attention on their heart
and they're giving their heart the
energy it needs to beat that's what that
frequency is about so you're feeding it
on an energy
so we see it kind of go up like a gas
tank and then we see the parasympathetic
nervous system come up with it and what
does that mean
the person's relaxing
right so now they're relaxing but then
all of a sudden we see the
parasympathetic nervous system about to
drop down and here comes the sympathetic
nervous system and on the person's
having a little arousal
and we started discovering that when
this occurs when a person is relaxed in
their heart and there's energy that
moves to the brain the person starts
seeing possibilities that they they
never saw before
and so
getting really good at relaxing in your
heart and Awakening your brain
causes this kind of synchronization that
takes place between the two they're
they're dancing together in this really
beautiful way and when they're in the
same or similar frequency if you're
sharing the same frequency you're
sharing the same information now the
brain may think but the heart knows
and I'm telling you it is a straight
shooter it does not beat around the bush
at all and now the heart starts telling
and forming the brain giving it the
information that the person needs for
themselves in their lives
and we can do this we take people that
we can train them to do this and they
can do it in 15 minutes
and when they start getting really good
at relaxing more in their heart and more
energy begins to move into their brain
we start seeing this very crazy thing
happen in the brain where delta waves
are now carrying theta waves and theta
waves are carrying alpha waves and alpha
waves are carrying beta waves and beta
waves are carrying High beta waves and
high waves carrying gamma waves in the
whole entire brain
is functioning resonance there are
patterns within patterns within patterns
within patterns and that person is
having a very profound
transcendental moment so we work with
getting really relaxed in our hearts and
awaken our brain we do it so much I want
people to get so good at doing it with
their eyes closed
they can do it with their eyes open
because relax in the heart and awake in
the brain is so much better than
stressed out unconscious and living in a
program what can we do on a moment by
moment basis when we catch ourselves and
realize we're riding our emotions
look I mean there's nothing wrong with
an emotional reaction I still have them
I mean we all do the question is how
long are you going to have it that's the
real question and if you can't break
that emotional reaction then it means on
some level you must be addicted to that
emotion because an addiction is
something you think you can't stop so
imagine then
when you start reacting most people
don't think that they have the ability
to stop it so they don't they think the
person out there is doing it to me or
that situation is creating it so once we
say that we're victims because we have
no control over ourselves so when we
start reacting the first thing to do is
to stop
take a breath Center yourself bring up
an elevated emotion and I know that a
lot of times you don't want to do it
because you want to feel angry and you
want to feel frustrated and you want to
feel fear because that's the normal
reaction
so so the first step in any process of
change is becoming aware so you may just
say my gosh now I'm aware that I'm angry
now that I'm aware that I'm fearful
that's the first step the second step is
doing something about it taking a moment
excusing yourself from the conditions in
your life just for a few minutes you're
centering yourself I just did it
yesterday centering myself taking a
couple breaths raising my energy and
working with my body so it's I don't I
don't do that for four hours because it
turns out we lose a lot of energy and we
also start down regulating genes that
start creating disease so so the second
step is really executing A Change by
creating an elevated State and so you
begin to lower the volume to those
survival emotions and of course you
begin to cultivate elevated emotions and
it makes sense that our students who
practice this every single day in doing
the inner work
is becoming a skill for them and we see
some students that are able to sustain
those States for over an hour at a time
which means they don't have all their
attention on their world now they're
actually paying more attention to their
inner world and they're not putting all
their attention out there and that's
what allows them to catch it when they
start feeling a certain way so so you
got to practice just like you just can't
go out and hit a tennis ball
unless you start practicing and the more
you practice and the more you do the
work
the same thing happens with your ability
to be able to regulate and change
different states because you made it
this far
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible Bruce Lipton motivation check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there ultimately I started
to recognize when things didn't work it
was possibly because there were better
ways to do it and I wasn't conscious of
it and so what I started to learn over a
period of time was simply this there's
an old saying there's a means to an end
and the idea